hey you might have noticed that we
didn't really talk about those coin
flips that allegedly gave victory in the
Iowa Democratic caucus to Hillary
Clinton my sense was that a lot of those
coin flip stories weren't accurate and
that indeed appears to be the case a
bunch of corporate media outlets have
been saying six consecutive coin tosses
that went in Hillary Clinton's favor
could have turned the outcome of the
entire caucus to Bernie Sanders had he
won those six consecutive coin tosses
and then people sort of disagreeing or
misunderstanding the math of how coin
tosses work the Des Moines Register
explained very clearly that these coin
flips assigned county-level delegates
they had an extremely small effect on
the overall outcome the confusion was
people believe that the coin flips were
used to determine state level delegates
now I am NOT defending the use of coin
flips in politics I i I'm not that's not
what I'm defending here I want to make
very clear is that when you talk about
county-level delegates many county-level
delegates for each of the precincts that
are involved in that Iowa caucus the
overall effect was almost none there
were a handful of democratic caucus
precincts where a delegate was awarded
with a coin toss these were up you there
they're just thousands and thousands of
these across the state from 1681
precincts not statewide delegate
equivalents but look at some of the
reporting that we saw from different
media outlets on this issue immediately
after this happened you saw reports from
for example uh and we have this to show
people NBC News political director Chuck
Todd basically we're talking a coin flip
may have decided the presidency that's
not true fox news for correspondent
shannon bream speculated that the 5 coin
tosses that five coin tosses could have
flipped the outcome fox's sean hannity
falsely claimed that the coin toss is
assigned state delegates and Drudge
Report saying America on a coin toss
also suggesting that this could have
flipped the result in Iowa that's just
not true Louis and I think people need
to understand that i
leave that Bernie Sanders is the more
progressive candidate I've been very
very clear about that but we shouldn't
now believe that the six coin tosses for
county-level delegates were going to
swing this thing in any way agreed I can
understand being outraged that coin
tosses were part of the process at all
sure and that's legitimate that's fine
but I'm not a Hillary fan at all on and
I'm not upset at this because I I
understand the scale we're talking about
absolutely but but still what we should
do away with the coin tosses there has
to be a better way I don't think we need
coin tosses in politics no doubt about
it now lastly there is confusion about
the math I saw some Hillary supporters
posting to Facebook you know the odds of
six heads in a row it's still 50 50
every time you flip a coin the odds are
fifty-fifty and then I saw Bernie
Sanders supporters saying this is
incredibly unlikely the odds that that
six coin flips in a row would go to
Hillary Clinton uh just incredibly low
let me explain the math once and for all
it is true that if you flip a coin one
time the odds of it coming up heads are
fifty-fifty assuming it's a sort of fair
coin it's been a weighted coin we
eliminate the incredibly rare
possibility that lands exactly on its
side which could happen conceivably
Louis in the physical world very very
unlikely anytime you flip a coin is
50-50 you get heads you flip it again
you still have a 50-50 chance of that
next flip coming up heads but this is a
different situation did the six coin
flip scenario is different because we're
asking about the odds of one specific
set of results six consecutive heads
results and the math is one-half or
fifty percent to the sixth power because
you're doing six of these coin flips the
coin flips one half times one half times
one half six times and that does get you
to about a one point five percent chance
of six heads flips in a row think about
it into of intuitively with roulette
roulette has 36 numbers plus zero and
double zero so there are 38 numbers the
odds that it comes up 23 on your first
spin are one in 38 let's say you hit 23
the odds that 23 comes up on the second
spin are also one in 38 but if what
you're saying before you take any spins
what are the odds
23 coming up two times in a row the odds
are 138th times 138 which is a very very
tiny number it was surprising to me
Louis the number of people who didn't
know the math on this basic probability
question uh yeah I guess so it's uh but
most people aren't having taken
statistics classes or whatever you would
take 22 you know I get you to realize
the math involved so whatever yeah I
mean even still you would think that uh
yeah anyway I guess we don't really have
to say more about it but that's the math
of it and let's understand the math
let's also understand these were
county-level delegates not state level
delegates and let's also understand that
we probably shouldn't have coin flips in
politics but let's not say that this
would have turned the Iowa caucus over
to Bernie Sanders because every
indication is that it would not have
done that i'm on twitter if you want to
comment about this at d pakman louis is
on twitter at louis MO tommy warby
parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses well the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check
the at-home trial and support our show
by going to warby parker dot-com / TDPS
it costs nothing